paul st pierre plamondon chef du parti
québécois bonsoir bonsoir je le disais
avant la pause
on écoute ça les etats unis se débat
hallucinant sur les armes les victimes
des jeunes victimes dans une école la
syrie des enfants prix alors oui
votre parti d'autres ont des problèmes
et on peut on peut se dire en commençant
que ça relativise nos problèmes sur le
sur la scène politique complètement
complètement c'est pas des problèmes
c'est des débats politiques qu'on
connaît qui sont normaux et j'écoute est
justement là les témoignages des parents
est exempt je me disais était au fond
faut continuer à garder espoir et à
veiller sur nos enfants revenir à
l'essentiel parce que si on veut que les
gens continuent à s'intéresser ou le
moindrement la politique et à
l'actualité va falloir également ne pas
amplifier des problèmes qu'ils n'en sont
pas juste une discussion des accords par
exemple entre lucien bouchard est moins
sûr comment on devrait amener
l'indépendance du québec mais c'est
important aussi de ramener à l'essentiel
à savoir que des tragédies comme cela on
n'en veut pas au québec on ne souhaite
pas pour les états unis non plus il faut
garder espoir là dedans puis il faut
militer pour protéger ses enfants et ça
nous dit que notre société
avec les défis qu'on a et quand même
tellement plus saine
notre cadre politique et sociale plus
simple puisqu'il passe au sud il faut
rien prendre pour acquis moi je
m'inquiète beaucoup de voir les
l'utilisation des armes à feu à montréal
au cours des dernières années et notre
incapacité à date à avoir une réponse
qui est adéquat quand une garderie
reçoit des balles par l'ape sa fenêtre
je pense la prise de conscience elle
doit avoir lieu ici également
c'est une discussion qui devrait prendre
plus de place qu'en ce moment à mon avis
très bien monsieur st pierre plamondon
monsieur vous avez parlé monsieur
bouchard qui dans un entretien et je le
souligne parce que des gens ont pris des
extraits depuis vendredi dernier à
droite et à gauche mais dans l'ensemble
oui il a été dur envers le parti
québécois actuellement oui bien sûr vous
l'avez vous l'avez entendu mais il a
aussi dit c'est courageux
j'ai du respect pour les militants qui
sont encore là mais selon moi c'est
irréaliste que de proposer un référendum
en 2022 sur ce point là en particulier
vous répondez quoi à monsieur bouchard
et aux obus je respecte l'opinion de
monsieur bouchard mais de mon point de
vue sincèrement je vois pas comment
notre projet nous devons avancer si on y
renonce si on les cache dans l'espace
public donc sous ma gouverne on assume
totalement qu'on souhaite que le québec
devienne un pays on dit aux québécois
qu'il le mérite d'un jour être un pays
et que le plus tôt sera le mieux étant
donné que l'actualité les relations avec
le fédéral le déclin du français de la
culture québécoise tous les lumineux
sont au rouge et il ya une solution pour
s'offrir une pérennité et linguistique
et culturel mais également exister à
l'étranger ça s'appelle l'indépendance
du québec comme chef moi j'ai fait le
choix d'assumer complètement et d'en
être fier de ne pas cacher nos
orientations politiques d'en faire la
promotion avec le plus de vigueur et de
fierté qui est possible de faire mais
que faites vous dans le contexte
politique où les québécois n'en veulent
pas de votre solution mais il ya en
veulent pas
les sondages sont assez constante en 30
et 40% ici on se contente de gouverner
strictement par sondage si le rôle du
politicien c'est de n'avoir aucune
vision et de consulter le sondage du
jour prendre toutes ces décisions en
fonction de sondage à quoi sert les
politiciens donc de mon point de vue le
leadership c'est dénoncer certaines
choses nécessaires et l'indépendance
elle est nécessaire et urgente à la
lumière de plusieurs pouvoirs qui nous
échappe à la lumière de notre droit
d'exister sur le plan linguistique et
culturelle quand le premier ministre du
québec en vient à dire que c'est une
question de survie pour la nation
québécoise
que dans les 48 heures il obtient un
refus c'est pas normal que ce
gouvernement ne soit même pas capable de
faire comme robert bourassa et évoqué la
possibilité notre indépendance nous on
va bien plus loin qu'on dit on doit la
faire c'est un beau projet c'est un
projet qui riche porteur d'avenir et on
veut le dire aux québécois en toute
franchise en toute sincérité oui
d'ailleurs vous aviez pris la balle au
bond
comme sur le go addition ne récupère pas
tous les pouvoirs en immigration
l'avenir du peuple québécois et
francophones est menacée c'est là vous
avez pris la balle au bond d'abord ben
allez au bout de votre logique monsieur
legault le staff c'est là que c'est
parti oui et monsieur legault n'a pas
été capable d'évoquer le moins
dépendance une seule fois mais là c'est
plus ça va plus loin il ya caroline
st-hilaire et bernard drainville qui se
porte candidat la cac et les deux non
plus ne sont sont complètement capable
de dire la vérité d'être honnête avec
les lecteurs dit ouais moi je suis
indépendantiste mais la vérité ou afin
aussi on n'est pas dans leur tête le
mais ils sont incapables de dire qu'ils
sont souverainistes en tout cas il ne
veut pas dire qu'ils sont sûrs et n'est
encore où et puis disons que à mon avis
ça manque de transparence avec
l'électorat
médicaments même prenons l'exemple de
révéler de saint-hilaire
ça vous arrive le coup sur coup ça vous
dit quoi quand même sur le contexte
politique actuel monsieur st pierre
plamondon ya un gouvernement qui est
largement en avance dans les sondages ça
lui permet d'offrir des comptes et sur
des ministères
le pouvoir donc les gens vont réagir
différemment pour autant ça n'empêche
pas une formation comme le parti
québécois d'attirer des gens de qualité
qui eux veulent défendre la cause
défendre leurs convictions et ce sera
aux électeurs de choisir parce que pour
nous au parti québécois et pour nous
indépendantiste il ya quand même quelque
chose de positif dans ce qui se passe en
ce moment il ya une ligne de démarcation
très clair qui est empreint de ce cri
d'un côté ceux qui sont résignés ceux
qui ne veulent pas se dire la vérité à
eux-mêmes quant à leurs convictions de
l'autre côté ceux qui sont optimistes
qui veulent voir le québec devenir un
pays et qu'il assume avec fierté qu'il
assume avec honnêteté donc ce sera à ce
moment le très clair pour les électeurs
il ya deux camps qui ne pensent qu'ils
ne voient pas notre avenir de la même
manière et vous dites faut l'assumer
keita avoir un ou deux députés en
octobre prochain
il n'y a pas de lien à mes yeux plus on
assume et plus on est honnête j'ose
croire que la sincérité les convictions
politiques ont une valeur c'est sûr
qu'en en période de pandémie on se
cachera pas que c'est un contexte dans
le cadre duquel les discussions sur
notre avenir avait beaucoup moins d'
espaces mais une campagne électorale
avec ce qui vient de se passer dans les
faits en ce moment parti québécois on
aura rarement vu autant de gens prendre
une carte de membre ou reprendre leur
carte il ya un effet où les gens
constatent que le gouvernement actuel ne
vaut même pas au niveau de nationalisme
de johnson ou de bourassa et ils se
disent bien voir ce qu'ils me disent la
vérité est qu'ils sont fiers de
l'indépendance mais moi je vais aller
soutenir donc rien n'est joué pour les
prochaines élections puis on a hâte de
porter fièrement avec droiture ce que
nous on croit profondément monsieur
bouchard faisait la différence entre
l'idée le rêve dit il qui doit rester
éveillé vivant de la souveraineté
éventuellement et diront ce dont
personne ne connaît l'avenir et le parti
québécois est d'ailleurs l'ont beaucoup
de gens disent beaucoup show cette
semaine on oublie que le pq a été assez
dur merci envers monsieur lévesque
également un verre tous ces chefs
we've et vice versa vous avez mesure
peut-être mais
on peut dire que parti québécois n'est
plus le véhicule qu'il faut et ce à
renoncer complètement à jamais toujours
à la souveraineté non mais c'est à dire
il ya un seul véhicule qui prône
l'indépendance comme un objectif
politique qu'on doit réaliser un seul
véhicule pour dire faut aller plus loin
sur le français faut nommer
l'indépendance comme un objectif urgent
donc je dire on est renouvelé on est
bien financé on est d'attaquer une
nouvelle génération d'indépendantistes
qui lèvent la main pourquoi ne pas
encourager le parti qui prendre cette
idée là si on est d'accord avec l'idée
on va se présenter comme on est aux
prochaines élections je pense que
l'accumulation des mauvaises nouvelles
faire en sorte nous allons corriger si
je me trompe que dans le fond
ça met en lumière un certain courage sur
ce qui reste alors il ya quelque chose
peut-être effectivement de positif oui
et ça attire d'autres gens qui pensent
en patriote bons qu'ils pensent un très
bien qu'ils sont pas dans une logique
coûts bénéfices mais qui servent la
cause avec honneur et il y aura des
annonces en ce sens là donc on aura une
belle équipe mais surtout une fraîcheur
une règle jusqu'au bout ça ce que vous
demain andré bouthillier du conseil
d'administration de la fondation rené
lévesque envoyé un communiqué dit
d'abord le programme est pas du tout
arrêter parce que lundi on disait que
j'ai tjrs est pas invité à parler à
montréal lors de la cérémonie qui lance
le coup d'envoi des festivités en fait
des commémorations du centième
anniversaire de monsieur lévesque et là
on nous dit battant dijon n'a jamais dit
ça d'abord vous étiez invité l'espoir
oui oui je suis invitée vous avez
mentionné mme anna parole en principe ce
monsieur françois legault et monsieur
lucien bouchard mais vous il n'y a pas
de cure à 6h03 d'orateur représentant le
parti québécois pour cet hommage à rené
lévesque même pas 17h41 lol vous n'avez
pas eu de nouvelles nouvelles pauvres
n'ont rien de neuf de mon côté vaut
suivre paul st pierre plamondon chef du
parti québécois merci nous avoir parlé
une bonne soirée à vous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i see her dit